the West is a browser adventure game for
hardcore western fans it's the
brainchild of Christine mutt who
co-developed the game
she works for Hamburg game manufacturer
in O games she comes up with basic game
designs and initial interface concepts
she's one of only a small number of
women in the profession as a there's
that old cliche that it's dry and dusty
and only nerds do it we sit in the
basement with a bunch of computers and
program things Christine Mudd is still
one of only a handful of women in the
company at innoGames about 15% of staff
are women
the company focuses on browser and
mobile games CEO Hindi Clint watt is
desperately looking to hire more staff
and he doesn't want them all to be men
diversity in the team is definitely an
advantage because it helps you appeal to
a broader group of people it's good for
developers to include women as well as
other groups that variety helps you
appeal to different target groups so
it's good to have representatives of
those on the team
male gamers tend to enjoy competition
women tend to prefer games where they
build or create something the private
school for games in Berlin trains new
generation game developers from graphic
design to programming the students can
learn it all from the ground up about
1/3 of the students are women and their
numbers are rising the school's
management says that's a logical
development women generally have a
smartphone or tablet in their bag then
there's games over Facebook which women
also use of course and other social
platforms and browser games so women
already have a relationship to games and
that helps spark an interest in
developing them tabhi aapko has decided
to focus on graphics Hamburg zinno games
is supporting her training with a
stipend the young woman wants to bring a
new approach to the industry
I don't the girls get annoyed that every
third character sports an E cup one that
still has a figure to die for they need
to be a bit more normal
take Lara Croft for example in early
versions she was still racing around in
hot pants the new Lara now wear sporty
cargo pants courtesy of British game
developer Rhianna Pratchett but not all
gamers like the idea in the US a debate
about sexism has flared up under the
hashtag gamergate it started with media
critic anita sarkeesian she discusses
the depiction of women in games on her
YouTube channel that unleashed a
firestorm of insults on Twitter and even
death threats of course it's worrying
when you see that there needs to be more
discussion education and that will
definitely help one thing's for sure the
new generation of female gamers and
developers is on the horizon chip says
take it to the next level